[Music]
[Applause]
he's been following us all day security
I want to do the show now because over
the last four years I've been dealing
with health challenges and particular
Lyme disease and I've not spent friends
with my body and it's time to make press
on my body again and get the joy back
and performing consistently because I've
been cited like home resting and resting
and resting which is helpful but it's
time to get moving and it's time to
overcome this thing once and for all
what better way than jumping on a
national TV show with dancing way to do
it and I feel like if I don't do that I
could get stuck and so I'm ready to get
unstuck and I think this is the way it's
the way to do it so we need to be even
knowing somebody personally I can see
how
thank you I feel like I feel like so
many people are sitting home dealing
with something that is making them feel
stuck or sidelines in their own life and
I looked I looked at my itinerary
yesterday and I just looked at the
accomplishment of what I've done in one
week I've done Wow why desist this I
used to look at my career in my life as
this giant picture and now I'm like
moment to moment day to day and I don't
know what's gonna happen next and all I
can do is show up and bring my best and
this guy is helping me do that he's been
so supportive thus far she might be the
best person ever
there's a lot to it yeah you know what
Alan is young and hungry and just
diligently putting together awesome
choreography and yeah we could have have
a very similar energy which is I think
why we were paired together it's gonna
be a lot of fun it has been already
building using the famous music videos I
did my research we'll get into them
[Music]
you
[Music]